bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo frais missions spéciales
cette semaine puisque notre invité c'est
pierre moscovici le commissaire européen
aux affaires économiques avec lui on
fera le tour de l'actualité européenne
la lutte contre le terrorisme et son
financement la crise des migrants mais
aussi la tentation du break site la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'europe
fantasme ou réalité en tout cas cette
année on va en parler conseil européen
en février référendum en juin leur
portage à londres de tivo le floch cette
semaine le premier ministre britannique
david cameron a affirmé qu'il ferait
campagne pour le maintien du royaume uni
au sein de l'europe à condition
d'obtenir à des réformes de l'union
européenne lors d'un sommet le mois
prochain
pierre moscovici a avant tout un domaine
de compétence c'est l'économie avec lui
on reviendra tout de suite sur sa
dernière prise de position publiée par
plusieurs journaux européens
le commissaire européen était ferme pas
de délais supplémentaires à la france
pour revenir sous les 3% de déficit en
2010 est regardée
droit dans ses bottes dia moscovici
le commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques qu affiche sa fermeté dans
un entretien publiée par plusieurs
journaux européens
il est catégorique pas question que la
france puisse bénéficier d'un délai
supplémentaire pour respecter ses
engagements budgétaires et ramener son
déficit public sous 3%
si la france fait l'effort structurel
suffisant elle peut évidemment être en
dessous de 3 % en 2017
elle a bénéficié deux fois d'un délai de
deux ans qui ne saurait être encore
prolongée effectivement la commission
européenne a accordé deux délai de deux
ans à la france là en 2013 et l'autre en
2015 pour ramener son déficit sous la
barre des 3% du pib en 2010 est un
objectif fixé par les traités dans
l'opposition on ironise sur la fermeté
affichée du commissaire européen
quand il était ministre en france l
essai
filer les déficits et la dépense
publique et n'a pas été capable de
respecter les engagements que la france
avait pris avec bruxelles
aujourd'hui de bruxelles doit rappeler à
la france que doit remplir ses objectifs
et tenir ses engagements voilà ma main
gauche ne sais pas ce que fait ma main
droite ou inversement je sais pas ce
qu'il en est en tous les cas en ce qui
concerne mais je souhaite bon courage
pourquoi dessus à gérer cette
contradiction
il y a deux ans pierre moscovici quitte
bercy avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli il se félicitait d'avoir
négocié un délai supplémentaire à la
france pour revenir sous les 3% de
déficit
après de longues discussions des
discussions que j'ai eues à mener pour
permettre que la france est un délai
pour passer en deçà de 3% du pib en
termes de déficit
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
contradiction rassure ses amis
politiques ne voit pas de contradiction
quand il y a des responsabilités il faut
les occuper et donc se créer des marges
de manoeuvre car respecter les choses ce
n'est pas la même chose on peut avoir la
même formation et on ne la fait pas la
même façon selon que l'on est avocat ou
s'ils vont tourner juge
on a des comportements qui peuvent être
différents on ne défend pas exactement
le moins de points de vue et donc je
crois qu'il ne faut pas chercher de
contradictions les contradictions elles
sont dans les valeurs et je pense que
dans ce qu'il fait pierre n'a pas de
contradiction et les valeurs qui sont
les siennes
après les attentats du 13 novembre le
président françois hollande avait estimé
que le pacte de sécurité l'emportait sur
le pacte de stabilité européen est
contraint la france a limité ses
déficits publics alors pierre moscovici
gardien du 3% de déficit
ne doit pas se réduire à cela lance ses
amis socialistes
j'espère pour pierre moscovici qu'il
n'est pas simplement le gardien des
chiffres mais pas seulement
le gardien des taux de déficit mais
qu'il est capable aussi d'inspirer des
changements politiques en europe et
c'est à ça qu'il doit s'atteler
maintenant est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe intervient suffisamment
fortement pour permettre à anne au pays
de retrouver des formes de croissance à
la croissance des trente glorieuses de
défendre de croissance nous valent
qu'ils soient riches en emplois et qui
assure également la transformation
écologique non l'europe n'est pas armée
pour cela le job de carnage prison même
si la croissance reste une priorité
le déficit français en 2010 cette année
d'élection présidentielle reste un enjeu
de première importance au niveau
européen alors nous envoie ce plateau
pierre moscovici bonjour merci jour
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
un entretien publiée par plusieurs
journaux l'opinion dessous deutsche
zeitung en allemagne la stampa l'italie
vanguardia en espagne et la même fermeté
pas de délais supplémentaires à la
france pour respecter ses engagements
budgétaires et ramener son déficit
public sous 3% de pib en 2010 cette
pierre moscovici c'est votre dernier mot
j'ai en effet été misés finances de la
france pendant deux ans je souris en
attendant monsieur pascal g des vagues
souvenirs de la politique et j'essaie
d'être très constant et fasquelle qui
disait je ne sais pas si voilà ma main
droite main gauche elle fait la même
chose c'est-à-dire que quand je suis
devenu ministre des finances en 2012
la france avait les déficits proches 5%
quand j'ai quitté le ministère elle
avait 1 % - et donc j'ai toujours eu
comme l'idée qu'il fallait baisser les
déficits que d'ailleurs le gouvernement
que soutenait monsieur fasquelle à
l'époque avait augmenté de manière très
forte mais j'arrête parce que je ne suis
plus un homme politique en tout cas pas
un homme politique dont le débat
partisan auquel on voudrait me tirer les
choses sont simples la france c'est vrai
a bénéficié de deux fois deux ans de
délai pour revenir en dessous de 3% et
ça n'a pas été une indulgence ni dans un
cas quand j'étais mis les finances ni
dans l'autre
j'étais commissaire européen c'est
simplement parce que
la croissance est faible alors que les
efforts structurels fait par le pays
sont disons suffisant même s'il pourrait
être accrue mais c'est clair deux fois
deux ans est exceptionnel et la
commission européenne ne peut pas aller
plus loin
n'ira pas plus loin mais en même temps
disant ça je suis surpris qu'on soit
surpris parce que c'est une telle
évidence
et d'ailleurs ce que j'ai voulu dire
c'est que la france était tout à fait en
capacité en mesure de remplir ses
objectifs pour 2016 c'est 3 3 ou 3 4% du
pib et si la croissance que nous
prévoyons se confirme comment parler
c'est vraisemblable c'est possible et
passer ensuite en 2017 certes je sais
que c'est une année électorale de 3,3 à
2,9 ou 2,8 puisque c'est l'engagement
voir 2,7 c'est tout à fait jouable et
donc je n'ai pas là mis la pression sur
la france
j'ai simplement rappeler des devoirs des
engagements qui sont ceux des traités
mais qui sont aussi tout simplement ceux
du pays et d'ailleurs je note que aussi
bien françois hollande que michel sappin
ont confirmé que ces engagements soient
tenus
donc je suis non pas devenir malcom
addiction mais je suis cohérent dans mon
action et dans le temps d'accord
françois hollande lui est dans mes
valeurs le françois hollande a détaillé
donc cette semaine les modalités de son
plan d'urgence contre le chômage pour
lequel la france va dépenser plus de 2
milliards d'euros dont 2 2 milliards
d'euros avec notamment une prime à
l'embauché de 2000 euros pour les pme
est-ce que c'est pas en contradiction
avec l'objectif des 3% des ventes comme
question pour le rappelait je suis
commissaire aux affaires économiques et
financières
j'ai pas je suis gardien des règles de
qualité mais je ne suis pas que cela est
en effet ce qui m'importe avant tout et
ce qui importe à la commission juncker
c'est la croissance et l'emploi
nous voulons clairement réorienter la
construction européenne
nous ne sommes pas pour l'austérité nous
sommes pour le sérieux des règles aussi
pour le dynamisme de l'économie
et quand j'entends le président la
république je pense avant tout à
l'efficacité du plan en matière d'emploi
et c'est ça que nous allons évaluer
j'espère sincèrement que ce plan
permettra de réduire le chômage en
france parce que c'est évidemment un
fléau qui mine la cohésion sociale et
qui touche très fortement nagera en
contradiction avec nos objectifs
absolument pas ce que souhaite la
commission européenne si avant tout que
ce 29e et à kehl chômage parce que nous
sommes 28 mai il ya près de 25 millions
de chômeurs en europe et la jeunesse est
touché du moins de 25 ans apprennent 25%
c'est à dire à peu près le taux en
france cette insupportable et donc tout
ce qui va dans le sens de la création
d'emplois de la croissance de
l'innovation l'investissement de la
réduction du chômage nous le saluerons
alors il faut voir si ces mesures sont
efficaces ou pas de toute façon il ya la
liberté
j'allais dire de moyens même si à une
obligation de résultat après il ya le
deuxième aspect qui suit vous soulignez
et l'aspect financier l'aspect
budgétaire 2 milliards d'euros
j'ai noté que le président de la
république comme l'a encore le musée
finances ont dit que ces deux milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
seraient couverts par des économies à la
même hauteur ce qui veut dire que ça
n'aura pas d'impact sur la trajectoire
budgétaire
je salue cet engagement et je veillerai
et la commission veillera à ce qu'ils
soient tenus parce que il ne faudrait
pas pour autant que ce plan pour
l'emploi
ce plan d'urgence et il est nécessaire
car il ya état d'urgence sur l'emploi
soit de nature à faire dévier la
trajectoire budgétaire la france
rappelant que du déficit en plus c'est
de la dette en plus et que de la dette
en plus c'est ce qu'on appelle du
service de la dette à travers les
intérêts c'est de la dépense publique
totalement inefficace un euro pour le
service de la dette
c'est un euro en moins pour l'éducation
pour l'hôpital pour la sécurité pour la
justice ou un euro en moins pour
l'économie pour la compétitivité pour la
création d'emplois c'est de la mauvaise
dépense publique
le chômage va peser vieme états de
l'union européenne pour pour lutter
contre le chômage faut de la reprise
économique faut de la croissance
vous vous avez des chiffres que vous
allez annoncé en février ce que la
reprise elle est là j'ai tendance à
penser que la reprise en europe est
solide parce qu'elle repose sur ce qu'on
appelle les vents favorables
il ya d'une part la baisse du prix du
pétrole les majeures il ya la politique
monétaire suivie par la banque centrale
européenne qui maintenant fait une
abondance de liquidités qui soutient la
croissance et qui vise à faire remonter
un peu le taux d'inflation et il n'ya
enfin le fait que
du fait précisément de cette politique
monétaire le taux de change entre l'euro
et le dollar s'est affaissé ce qui est
favorable à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises lorsqu'elles exporte
notamment les entreprises industrielles
donc je dirais une reprise solide parce
qu'en plus il ya eu une réduction de
déficit
même si en france il reste encore des
efforts à faire et il ya eu aussi des
réformes structurelles
même si là encore en france il y a des
efforts à faire que j'encourage vivement
christian paul disait que me pierre
moscovici son job c'est de réunir les
conditions d'une croissance créatrice
véritablement créatrice d'emplois
socialement moi je me sens pas du tout
aujourd'hui le défenseur d'une politique
d'austérité
je pense que sérieux budgétaire réformes
structurelles investissements à travers
vous savez ce plan qu'on appelle le plan
juncker un plan massif de 315 milliards
d'euros dont la france devrait être une
des principales bénéficiaires parce
qu'elle a je pense de beaux projets de
belles entreprises innovantes dans la
recherche dans l'efficacité énergétique
dans le numérique voilà effectivement
mon job c'est la lutte contre le chômage
mais elle n'est pas contradictoire du
sérieux budgétaire
entre temps il ya eu les attentats
françois hollande a dit que le pacte de
sécurité a les engagements financiers
pour pour assurer la sécurité des
français primait sur le pacte de
stabilité qui comptera la france à
réduire son déficit vous comprenez cette
prise de position witch et les comprise
n'a pas choqué quand un pays il se
trouve que c'est la france
il se trouve que c'est mon pays il se
trouve que je laime mais un pays
européen est touché par des attentats
qui font 130 morts dans sa capitale des
jeunes jétais lors de la cérémonie aux
invalides comme connais tout le monde
bouleversé par l'énoncé de ces noms qui
aujourd'hui ne retrouvent plus leurs
familles et leurs familles ne retrouve
plus bien quand un pays est touché de
cette façon là qu'il est amené à faire
des défenses supplémentaires pour faire
face au terrorisme pour assurer la
sécurité de ses concitoyens
on le comprend et donc nous avons dit
que ces dépenses supplémentaires ne
seraient pas comptabilisées comme les
autres elles sont comptabilisés à part
mais cela dit j'observe qu'il s'agit de
dépenses je dire modéré
ceci entre 600 millions et valuation
basse et 815 millions évaluation ottmar
elhadj je veux pas être technique mais
ça fait quelque chose comme 0v le 0 15 %
du pib ça n'est pas de nature
faire dévier la trajectoire des finances
publiques françaises d'autant qu'il y
avait eu là encore je veux pas être
technique une ressource émergents
justement du prélèvement européen tel
qu'il est affecté dans le budget
national qui fait que non ça ne
devraient pas faire changer les choses
et là encore michel sapin avec qui
j'entretiens des relations
professionnelles étroite
outre qu'elles sont aussi amicalement
plus que convenable michel sapin s'est
engagé à ce que les 3% soit respectée en
ce qui suppose de passer par 3,3 en 2016
nous sommes juste sur ce cette tendance
mais il faut y veiller
je montre justement michel sapin on va
l'écouter tout de suite à la lutte
contre le terrorisme et surtout son
financement c'est la préoccupation des
états européens
écoutons le ministre français des
finances qui lance des pistes pour
lutter contre le financement du
terrorisme
on écoute et on réagit juste après
le premier outil celle échange
d'informations un bon échange
d'informations entre les pays entre les
organismes peuvent être différents d'un
pays à l'autre qui recueille
l'information sur les mouvements
financiers pour que chacun puisse dire
on lie à telle personne que je surveille
telle autre personne qui me paraît
dangereuse est-ce que vous avez des
informations précises sur les mouvements
financiers qui entoure cette personne
voilà l'échangé d'informations sur les
mouvements financiers des personnes
susceptibles de préparer des attentats
est ce que c'est opérationnel pierre
moscovici je sais que la commission je
sais que vous vous y travaillez comment
on peut tahrir concrètement gabor
processus aux financements des terres
orientales
parce que vous vous doutez bien pour
mener une opération comme celle de paris
avec ses ramifications internationales
il faut des moyens financiers qui sont
assez conséquents et que ne peuvent pas
comme ça a généré de chic les les
auteurs des attentats eux mêmes il y à
des filières et les sources de
financement on les connaît il ya ce
qu'on appelle les pics cogne vous savez
c'est ce mode de paiement nouveau euros
il ya ce qu'on appelle aussi les cartes
prépayées cartes prépayées qui comme
leur nom l'indiqué sont aussi anonyme et
dont le paiement est fait par
anticipation
il ya le trafic d'oeuvres d'art parce
que des ch tis une organisation qui se
définit comme un état
pis aussi des trésors et par rapport à
ça il faut une réponse qui soit
extrêmement articulé qui est justement
mettre fin à l'anonymat et qui
permettent aussi de mieux réguler et de
mieux contrôler le trafic des oeuvres
d'art par exemple je suis vous l'avez
rappelé commissaire aux affaires
économiques et financières mais je tiens
beaucoup aussi à la fiscalité et l'autre
à lanières je veux saluer nos douanes
parce que les prises que font les
douanes le contrôle des douanes est tout
à fait décisif et donc nous allons
présenter ce grand plan d'ensemble parce
que c' est un des piliers un des pans
essentiels de la lutte contre le
terrorisme que d'être capable d'assécher
les sources du financement de ce
terrorisme parce que il faut que ces
réseaux qui sont plus ou moins dormant
cesse d'être alimentée par des moyens
qui sont des moyens quasi étatique
donc nous allons traiter
systématiquement pour les mentionner
trois mais ce n'est pas le moins
important le bitcoin où c'est moyen de
paiement nouveau les cartes prépayées ou
financement à travers le pillage
d'oeuvres d'art et le trafic d'oeuvres
d'art
ça ce sont des choses qui doivent cesser
et il faut pour cela un plan européen
mais attention hein je le précise parce
que parfois une ambiguïté à plan
européen c'est une proposition la
commission européenne c'est une décision
des ministres et c'est une mise en
oeuvre coordonnée entre les états par
exemple les douanes je suis commissaire
aux douanes les douanes sont nationales
et elle travaille damas entre elles
hermès comme ici l'autre grande
actualité qui va occuper l'europe ses
proches à moi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
breakbeat une sortie éventuelle du
royaume uni de l'europe un référendum en
grande-bretagne est prévue d'ici à la
fin de l'année a peut-être en juin
thibault le floch est allé prendre le
pouls des partisans des opposants à la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'europe
le reportage à londres de thibault le
floch
cela c'est au château
partir ou rester dans l'union européenne
à c'est la question qui agite les
britanniques pour la deuxième fois de
son histoire le royaume uni va organiser
un référendum sur sa possible sortie de
l'union européenne la première fois
c'était dans les années 70 deux ans
après leur adhésion à l'union
les britanniques sont appelés aux urnes
pour savoir s'ils veulent poursuivre
l'aventuré européenne
le oui l'emporté alors à près de 67 pour
cent trente ans plus tard toujours la
même question mais cette fois les
eurosceptiques entend bien remporter la
bataille
les britanniques ont vu comment l'europe
a évolué c'est devenu une union de plus
en plus politisée avec un contrôle sur
nos lois et notre politique publique
c'est pourquoi les gens sont de plus en
plus agacé par le fait que nous faisons
partie de cette organisation pour
laquelle ils n'ont pas voté
le référendum ne devrait pas avoir lieu
avant juin 2016 mais les eurosceptiques
se sont déjà lancés dans la bataille de
communication sur internet
tout concourt à nous situer plutôt
quelque chose a une fin
l'ex plus tôt
nous traitons beaucoup
ainsi les gens voient que ce mouvement
se propage dans le pays
et ça les encourage à faire la même
chose tracter dans la rue faire du porte
à porte
bref ça nous aide à former les groupes
pour faire campagne
'l'indice d'eurosceptiques les plus
actifs dans cette campagne c'est le
député européen daniel hannan sur les
réseaux sociaux
ils partagent les photos de tous et
tractage contre l'union européenne quand
il n'est pas à maidstone il est à
canterbury ou bien encore à brighton
l'union europé ens a changé et on va
trouver une espèce de l'association
quelque chose il faut le faire pas le
vrai clip pro et anti briques sites sont
au coude à coude dans les sondages
des débats commencent à s'organiser dans
les villes britanniques
et ce soir-là brighton daniel hannan
défend sa position à coups d'arguments
économiques
nous faisons plus de commerces avec la
belgique qu'avec toute la chine
pourquoi parce que nous ne pouvons pas
signé d'accord de libre-échange avec la
chine
c'est le rôle de l'union européenne mais
regardez la suisse ils sont dans le
marché européen et ils ont un accord
commercial avec la chine depuis 2014
nous aussi longtemps que nous resterons
dans l'union européenne
nous ne pourrons pas faire pareil face
aux conservateurs caroline lui casse la
chef des écologistes britanniques
allaient pour le référendum gars et
démocratique mais elle milite contre la
sortie de la grande-bretagne à je ne
pense pas que l'union européenne soit
parfaite mais le gouvernement
britannique où les nations unies ne sont
pas parfait non plus et je ne voudrais
pas qu'on l'équipe
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on reste dans
lieux que l'on travaille avec les autres
pays pour rendre l'union plus
responsable et plus transparente plus
démocratique
on a plus de chance de résoudre les gros
problèmes mondiaux en travaillant avec
les autres plutôt qu en leur tournant le
dos
à l'image de la salle les britanniques
restent divisés sur la question du bric
site tout comme les politiques
reste à savoir quel sera le
positionnement des géants de l'économie
britannique qui profitent du marché
unique
il va peut-être s'est passé ce qu'il
s'est passé pour le référendum en écosse
l'indépendance de l'ecosse était et est
passé pas très bon il y avait même des
sondages juste avant le référendum qui
donnait la victoire des indépendantistes
sauf que dans les tous derniers dans le
dans la dernière ligne droite dans les
toutes dernières semaines voir dans les
tous derniers jours les milieux
économiques ont commencé à prendre peur
on fait une campagne massive qui a très
bien marché pour leur camp qui a fait
peur à l'ensemble des écossaises si
jamais l'indépendance arrivée qu'est-ce
qui se passerait pour tous pour nos
retraites etc
et hop les écossais finalement se sont
rétractés ici au royaume uni les milieux
économiques n'ont pas encore vraiment
donné de la voix et que quand ils vont
le faire
je pense que là là pas mal de
britanniques vont avoir peur et vont se
dire bon on va peut-être rester dans
l'europe même si on va arracher
peut-être quelques concessions je pense
que des lits cameron compte là dessus
avec un produit intérieur brut en
augmentation de plus de 2%
la grande bretagne fait partie des
économies les plus dynamiques de l'union
européenne et les grands groupes
industriels espèrent bien qu'il en
restera ainsi
c'est pourquoi des entreprises comme
airbus ford et bmw ont annoncé
publiquement qu'une sortie de la
grande-bretagne pourrait avoir des
conséquences néfastes sur l'économie
britannique
mais le choix appartient désormais aux
sujets de sa majesté
voilà un reportage de thibault le floch
le président de la commission européenne
le jean claude juncker s'est dit
quasiment sûr de parvenir à un accord
sur les réformes demandées par la grande
bretagne pour rester dans l'union
européenne
on va vers une sortie de crise pierre
moscovici jean claude pierre est un
homme qui parle rarement pour ne rien
dire et donc s'il a été aussi affirmé il
a eu des assurances
c'est lui même qui mènent cette
négociation avec le premier britannique
avec les états membres
c'est qu'il a la conviction que cet
accord est non seulement possible dans
ce monde nécessaire mais qu'il est
vraisemblable et donc moi je lui fais
confiance pour le négocier mais vous
savez au fond quelle équation dans cette
affaire-là
soyons clairs je pense qu'une sortie du
royaume uni c'est une option négative et
pour les britanniques et pour l'union
européenne
l'option gagnant gagnant c'est un
royaume uni dans une europe unie
la difficulté c'est qu'il faut à la fois
sans doute qu'il y ait des modifications
qui permettent au premier ministre
cameron de dire voilà dans la
négociation j'ai obtenu quelque chose
pour convaincre les britanniques mais
qu'en même temps ces modifications ne
remettent pas en cause de façon
fondamentale notre acquis communautaire
nous voulons la grande bretagne dans
l'europe
mais nous tenons à ce que l'europe soit
une europe unie qui conserve ses valeurs
et je citerais notamment deux choses
auxquelles je suis très attaché
personnellement d'une part la libre
circulation ce qu'on appelle schengen
dont la compagnie ne fait pas partie
mais schengen et la libre circulation ça
peut être modifié ça peut être renforcée
ça doit l'être
je pense notamment la proposition que
fait la commission de créer un corps de
gardes frontières pour mieux protéger
nos frontières à vis des rieurs contexte
indispensable mais pas mettre fin à une
circulation et la deuxième chose c'est
que la grande bretagne ne fait pas non
plus partie de la zone euro et on doit
pouvoir à la fois respecter la bretagne
dans les liens entre la zone euro la
grande-bretagne mais pas non plus
remettre en cause la zone européenne ce
qui va pouvoir avancer même dans la
construction de la zone euro plus
démocratique vous le dites vous-même
pierre moscovici l'année britanniques
participent à minima la vie de l'union
elles ont gardé leur monnaie ils sont
pas dans la zone euro pas dans schengen
sur la plupart des gros sujets ils ont
obtenu des dérogations des exemptions à
comme sur le budget européen de femmes
rabais britannique de thatcher a appelé
want my money back est ce que ce serait
si grave que ça que les britanniques
sorte pour de bon de l'union européenne
je pense que d'abord ce serait
économiquement difficile que ça nous
affaiblirait aussi dans les négociations
internationales que la grande bretagne
est une partie intégrante du grand
marché intérieur de l'union européenne
et que aussi comme signal politique ce
serait extrêmement négatif parce que ça
voudrait dire que l'europe qui s'est
toujours construit pas addition au fond
nous étions départ 6 une demande et 9 12
nous sommes unifiée avec l'europe de
l'est cette europe elle attire ya encore
des pays qui sont candidats il ya des
pays comme la macédoine mais aussi la
turquie qui est un grand pays candidat à
l'union européenne même si son adhésion
n'est pas pour demain nous avons besoin
de coopérer beaucoup avec elle notamment
pour faire face à la crise des réfugiés
donc l'europe est un projet attractif
le jour où ça devient un projet dont on
se sépare où il ya une défaisance il y a
aussi des fiances et donc je pense que
oui l'un dans l'autre nous avons intérêt
à rester ensemble nous avons besoin de
rester ensemble mais la question qui se
pose comme toujours de négociations
c'est à quel prix et c'est ce qui va
maintenant se décider dans les semaines
qui viennent puisque en principe c'est à
la fin février dans un concert opéra que
l'accord dont parlait jean claude
juncker et comme je le souhaite doit se
nouer la moscovie si vous êtes
commissaire européen jusqu'en 2019 très
brièvement vos chantiers prioritaires
d'abord la croissance l'emploi je les
dis et puis un chantier dont on n'a pas
parlé je regrette mais je suis conscient
aussi l'abri mais tu es d'entretien
c'est la fiscalité et en la matière je
défend une cause obstinément et je le
ferai jusqu'au bout la lutte pour la
transparence fiscale
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale contre
l'érosion des bases fiscales et si je
devais résumer mon action à un slogan
elle couvre beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
c'est faire en sorte que les entreprises
notamment les multinationales payent des
impôts là où et créer des profits je ne
supporte plus et les européens ne
supporte plus non plus la situation dans
laquelle il ya de l'opacité
on a la sensation que alors que les
citoyens font des efforts contre la
crise les multinationales elles sont
exonérées d'impôt payent peu ou pas
d'impôts ou bien
délocalisent leur imposition vers des
pays où la position est faible donc la
transparence est aussi ce qu on appelle
l imposition effective ça ce sera pour
moi un chantier décisif
j'ai déjà commencé cette commission est
la plus ambitieuse je peux le dire qui
ait jamais existé sur le plan de la
transparence fiscale
après 2019 après votre poste de
commissaire européen on parle de vous
comme candidat possible à la
présidentielle française en 2022
c'est trop loin celui qui parlerait
aujourd'hui de la présidentielle et lula
ne je ne me permets de rectifier je peux
avoir mes défauts liona comprennent pas
toujours c'est d'être totalement stupide
ou imprudents et donc je ne ferai jamais
jamais ce genre de pronostics ou ce
genre de paris la présidentielle domaine
22 c'est un autre univers il y en a une
autre ça vous aura maggiore soixante
quatre ans il paraît qu'elle est
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
prochaine qui pourrait être plus vieux
mais en attendant non je n'y pense pas
en trois ans puisque vous voyez je me
rase on peut même si quand même il faut
se raser de manière savante pour avoir
une barbe qui correspondent à quelque
chose non en 2019 fin 2019
je verrai qu'elle est d'abord le bilan
de mon action
j'aurais 62 ans une grande expérience
public j'aurais été vingt ans
parlementaire 7 ans mini 5 ans
commissaire européen pour y arrêter la
politique alors je verrai de quelle
façon je peux être le plus utile à la
société à mon pays si c'est la politique
c'est quelque chose que je connais et
que j'aime
si cet autre chose je serai capable je
crois de passer à cette autre vie et
donc non je ne fais pas de plans sur la
comète jusqu'en novembre 2019 ya encore
quatre ans nous sommes dans une europe
en crise l'europe en crise a besoin
qu'on y consacre toute son énergie et
toute mon énergie
tout le talent que je peux avoir grand
ou petit est voué à sa faire en sorte
que l'europe aille mieux
et pour ce qui est de ma fibre française
faire en sorte que les relations entre
la france et l'europe soit plus saines
soit meilleur on a besoin finalement à
forte dans une europe forte
ça va ensemble parce que l'europe ne
marche pas quand la france ne marche pas
et l'europe ne marche pas
sans idées françaises j'essaie d'y
apporter mes pieds sera le mot de la fin
merci pierre moscovici d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à celle afin d' europe
hebdo merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
un bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf